yeah I got like 3 000 followers how
often you posted a day on Tick Tock like
once every week or two weeks bro the
woman was too stunned to speak you can
make one Tick Tock video flashing your
[__] and you can get five million
organic views overnight so what's the
problem tell me before insecurity like
fear like that the kids are even too
young for you kind of [__] Tick Tock
still is looked as corny a little bit to
some people [__] posts it's not corny
it's gonna be the [__] framework I
need to do without because I hear from
your YouTuber do it I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna jump into that
photo and say you're a dick if you're
not posting two times a day on tick tock